Transcription: Diana de Vega de Ceniga
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir à tous
et bienvenue pour cette thématique,
« Le lean, une recette miracle ».
A nouveau, avec la lumière
je ne vous vois pas bien mais...
Qui parmi vous a déjà entendu
parler de lean ?
Je vous laisse lever la main pour que
je voie à peu près à qui je m'adresse.
Gardez les mains levées,
laissez les mains levées,
et parmi ces mains levées, qui a déjà eu
l'occasion de travailler avec le lean ?
Qui le connaît ?
Tout de suite un peu moins de mains
et parmi ces derniers Gaulois,
qui se sentirait capable en
une ou deux phrases d'expliquer le lean ?
(Rires)
Eh bien, le lean -
je vais déjà m'adresser à ceux
qui n'ont jamais entendu parler de ça,
parce que c'était comme même
à peu près la moitié des personnes -
pour faire simple,
c'est une grande boite à outils
et avec des outils d'amélioration.
Alors, principalement utilisés
dans l'industrie,
mais qui sont tout à fait adaptables
à l'administration ou au service.
Moi, si je devais vous définir
le lean en une phrase,
ce serait la suivante :
« Apprendre à aimer faire mieux
avec moins. »
Et pour ce faire, pour vous montrer
un petit peu ce qu'est le lean,
et ce que j'entends derrière cette phrase,
je ne vais pas vous parler de la théorie,
je ne vais pas vous expliquer les outils
et vous dire en quoi tel et tel outil
sont géniaux
et font des gains en entreprise.
Je ne vais pas non plus vous exposer
des cas d'entreprises
avec des pourcentages,
des milliers d'euros gagnés.
Ce n'est pas mon objectif ce soir.
Mon objectif ce soir,
c'est de vous faire participer,
pour certains,
à votre premier chantier lean.
Est-ce que vous avez envie de participer
à votre premier chantier lean ?
Public : Oui !
Ah ! Merci.
Vu que l'heure commence à tourner
et que la nuit est tombée,
on va faire un atelier de cuisine.
(Rires)
Vous les connaissez tous.
Pour m'aider
je vais faire appel à Alex, ici,
qui va relever les temps.
On va s'intéresser au temps
que je mets à produire ces articles.
Ça va être le produit
qu'on va travailler aujourd'hui
et j'ai un client qui m'a commandé
deux commandes de cinq brochettes.
Là, les couleurs sont importantes.
J'ai du rose et du blanc.
Et je vais faire des brochettes.
Si vous le voulez bien,
j'aimerais que vous deveniez tous dans
cette salle des experts du lean ce soir.
Est-ce que vous en avez envie ?
Public : Oui.
Ce n'est pas très compliqué.
Certains doivent se dire :
« Mais comment il veut qu'on devienne
des experts ? Il nous a à peine expliqué
de quoi il parlait. »
Eh bien, tout simplement en observant
ma façon de travailler
et en notant des idées d'amélioration
pour qu'on essaye de faire les choses
un peu plus rapidement par la suite.
Je vais avoir besoin d'un décompte
à partir de trois
pour que je puisse commencer
à travailler sur mes brochettes.
Trois,
Public : Deux.
Public : Un.
Public : Go !
Merci.
Je vais prendre mes cinq premiers pics,
car j'ai une première commande
de cinq qui est tombée.
Le premier Chamallow à mettre.
Je vais aller dans le garde-manger.
Combien dois-je en prendre
si je dois faire une commande de 10 ?
Sachant qu'il y a deux chamallows roses.
Oui ! il est tard,
je vous fais faire des calculs.
Normalement cinq fois deux, ça fait 10.
Donc j'ai mon premier garde-manger
qui est là
et je vais tout simplement commencer
à assembler mes brochettes.
Donc je commence par mettre
le premier rose
et puis je ferai toute ma commande
comme ça
et après le chamallow rose,
on va mettre le chamallow... ?
Public : Blanc.
Nickel !
Donc je vais retourner à mon garde-manger
et j'en prends combien ?
Vous voyez que vous êtes déjà des experts.
Ben, oui, on ne mélange pas
les roses et les blancs,
une table pour chaque.
Ce n'est pas les plus belles brochettes
que vous verrez dans votre vie mais...
je fais au mieux.
Et pour finir,
je reviens ici.
Il m'en reste deux pour finir
la première commande
et Alex va prendre le temps
à partir du moment où je peux livrer
la première pièce à mon client,
donc la première pièce est livrée.
Et puis, simplement je recommence.
Là je ne suis pas très bon,
je ne sais pas compter,
je n'en avais pris que quatre.
Il va m'en manquer un petit peu,
donc je les reprends dans mon garde-manger
et je refais exactement la même opération
pour faire ma deuxième commande.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà des idées
de comment je pourrais améliorer
ma façon de faire ?
Un petit peu ? Oui, dites que
je suis mauvais aussi ?
Tac !
Hop !
On est bientôt au bout.
Tac.
Allez, on a bientôt fini nos brochettes,
combien j'en ai ?
Ah ! Là ! Je l'avais perdue.
Et je finis ici et puis Alex du coup
va prendre le temps
que j'ai mis à réaliser
la dernière pièce, donc
la dixième brochette.
Là je me suis dépêché.
Voilà, c'est tout bon.
Alors, Alex est-ce que tu peux nous donner
le temps pour la première brochette?
Une minute vingt-quatre.
J'ai été plus rapide que dans mes
répétitions, je faisais une minute trente.
Et pour la dernière pièce, s'il te plaît ?
Alex : 55 secondes.
Anthony d'Errico : Pour la dernière ?
D'accords, tu es sûr ?
(Rires)
J'ai mis 55 secondes à sortir les 10 ?
Le temps total ?
Ah non ! C'était l'inverse, pardon !
Au total, j'ai mis combien de temps ?
1:24.
(Brouhaha)
Les calculs, ce n'est pas mon truc,
c'est pour ça que j'ai pris un assistant.
(Rires)
2:19 ? Eh bien, on peut noter 2:19.
Je compte sur vous maintenant que
vous êtes devenus des experts en lean
pour me proposer des améliorations
pour essayer de faire mieux
toujours pour livrer
ces dix brochettes au client.
Je vous laisse me dire
si vous avez des idées.
Allez-y, allez-y.
Ah! Oui ?
(Question du public)
Ça, c'est une excellente question,
je pense que Monsieur est connaisseur
un petit peu du lean
et c'est un concept qui s'appelle :
pièce à pièce.
C'est exactement ce qui a été expliqué :
c'est le fait de traiter une brochette
du début à la fin
avant de passer à autre chose.
Donc on va essayer de mettre ça en place.
Une autre idée ?
(Propositions du public)
Piocher directement dans ce bol-là ?
Je ne sais pas si vous avez vu mais dans
mon bol il y en a des roses et des blancs.
Est-ce qu'on ne peut pas aller plus loin
que les piocher dans le bol ?
(Discussions)
Les pré-trier ?
Les deux fabrications d'un coup,
comment ça ?
(Discussions)
Oui.
Aller 10 d'un coup et du coup
brochette par brochette.
C'était l'idée de...
C'est très contre-intuitif, brochette
par brochette mais vous allez voir que...
Eh bien, allez, on est partis,
donc je vais faire un pré-tri
j'aurai mes roses la et mes blancs là.
Les blancs on va les laisser
là-dedans, ils sont très bien.
Rapprocher les bols - j'avais
deux tables d'assemblage
parce que les brochettes ce n'est pas très
gros je peux tout faire sur une table ?
Ah !
(Rires)
On va tout mettre sur celle-là.
C'est ça.
Je crois qu'on n'est déjà pas mal.
Vous venez de vivre votre
première réimplantation d'atelier.
Voilà ! Des termes un peu barbares,
mais ce n'est ni plus ni moins que
mettre les choses bout à bout.
Ça paraît logique mais des fois
ça peut vite être compliqué.
Je vous propose de repartir,
à part s'il y a encore une idée
qu'on pourrait mettre en place ?
En même temps, c'est déjà pas mal.
Je vous disais
qu'on était capable de faire
mieux avec moins,
nous n'avons plus qu'une table.
On est prêts à repartir ?
Allez ! À nouveau,
il me faudra un décompte.
Trois,
Public : Deux.
Public : Un.
Public : Go.
La première pièce est sortie !
La première pièce est sortie.
Ah oui, j'ai été rapide !
Il fallait être attentif !
Public : Non, non.
Ouh là ! Problème qualité !
(Rires)
J'en profite,
On a un problème qualité.
Si jamais j'avais fait mes cinq brochettes
avec les cinq mêmes erreurs, j'aurai mis
un peu de temps à m'en rendre compte,
J'aurais dû attendre que ça arrive
tout au bout
pour m'apercevoir de l'erreur.
D'où l'importance de traiter
une chose à la fois.
Nos parents nous disaient ça,
je suis encore assez jeune mais...
on me l'a toujours dit.
Ah ! Ça, ça pourrait être
une deuxième amélioration !
Public : Deux bols de roses.
Deux bols de roses.
On n'est pas tous ambidextres.
(Rires)
Je ne sais même plus
à combien j'en suis...
(Non!) (Rires)
Vous, vous suivez pour moi, hein?
Quelqu'un me...
(Rires)
Je ne sais pas qui c'est qui m'a fait
changer les bols de place mais...
(Rires)
Est-ce que quelqu'un
a compté les brochettes ?
Parce que du coup là... Encore une ?
Public : Non !
(Rires)
Et top !
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Est-ce qu'on a été moins mauvais ?
Combien avait-on fait
pour sortir la première commande
et combien a-t-on fait cette fois-ci ?
Là on est à 10 secondes deux
alors qu'on était à... ?
(Discussion)
Alors...
Sur la série d'avant,
avant de vous proposer les améliorations,
2:19, au total ?
Ok. Et là pour sortir les 10 ?
1:06 ?
Alors 1:16, on est passé de deux à un,
je ne suis pas très bon en maths
comme vous avez pu le voir
mais nos amis statisticiens pourront faire
le calcul assez rapidement.
On a quasiment divisé par deux le temps
pour réaliser 10 brochettes.
Et pourtant je n'ai absolument pas changé
ma façon de faire les brochettes.
Je prenais toujours le pic et j'enfilais
les différents chamallows dessus.
(Discussion)
C'est ça !
Si on continuait, on pourrait du coup
mettre trois bols comme ça a été proposé.
Et c'est tout le principe du lean
et de l'amélioration continue :
c'est l'amélioration en continue
par petites itérations.
Ça ne sert à rien de faire
un grand changement
ou de penser à des grands changements
qui ne viendront jamais
mais l'idée est de faire des petites
améliorations qui, mises bout à bout,
créent de vrais gains.
Alors, je vous remercie
d'avoir participé à ce petit atelier.
Là, je le mets en gros,
parce que le lean, on ne sait
peut-être toujours pas d'où ça vient -
le lean, ce sont des ingénieurs américains
qui sont allés espionner -
ils étaient plus ou moins consentants -
les Japonais, les Japonais chez Toyota.
Ils y sont allés après la Seconde
Guerre mondiale, je vous rassure,
ils n'ont pas essayé pendant.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils sont allés faire ?
Ils sont allés observer
le système de production de Toyota.
Ils sont revenus aux États-Unis
et ils ont écrit des centaines d'ouvrages
où ils ont théorisé
ce que faisaient les Japonais.
Mais vu que le lean est originaire
du Japon,
et tout à l'heure,
on a entendu parler d'Ikigai -
décidément ces Japonais,
ils sont très présents -
j'aimerais vous donner un deuxième mot,
au-delà du lean.
Au Japon, ce dont on entend parler,
c'est le Kaizen.
Certains viennent de le souffler,
je suppose qu'il y a pas mal de bilingues,
qui savent en japonais
ce que ça veut dire.
Kai-zen,
ça veut dire : « changer pour le mieux ».
Et c'est exactement ce qu'on a fait là.
On a changé pour le mieux.
D'où c'est venu ?
C'est venu de la Seconde
Guerre Mondiale au Japon.
Il faut se mettre à la place d'un Japonais
qui sort de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Il y avait tout à reconstruire
et il n'y avait pas grand-chose.
Donc ils ont dû partir de rien
et faire preuve d'une mentalité très
japonaise qui est le bon sens paysan.
Tout à l'heure, quand on disait avoir
trois bols ici pour faire mes brochettes,
vous m'avez proposé l'idée,
je l'ai mise en place.
On n'est pas dans un système
qui est bureaucratique
où pour mettre un bol en place,
il faut que j'aille valider
à quatre niveaux de hiérarchie au-dessus :
on voit une action, on le fait.
C'est un mot japonais,
retenez-le, changer pour le bon,
vous le verrez aussi
dans d'autres domaines,
il n'apparaît pas que dans le lean.
Si on devait reprendre la définition
que je vous ai donnée au début :
« Apprendre à aimer faire mieux
avec moins »,
le challenge de faire mieux avec moins,
je pense qu'on l'a réussi
à travers l'atelier.
Les gains qu'on a eus là,
ils sont transposables à l'industrie,
ils sont transposables à l'administration.
Quand on réalisé des chantiers pareils.
J'aimerais qu'on aille
juste un petit peu plus loin
dans les verbes que j'ai utilisés,
parce qu'ils ne sont pas là par hasard.
Le premier, c'est « apprendre ».
Pour apprendre,
il faut avoir de l'écoute
et de l'humilité.
Et là je vous ai montré une première étape
où je réalisais des brochettes.
Peut-être que ces brochettes,
on m'a appris à les faire comme ça,
et peut-être que c'est 20 ans
que je les faisais comme ça.
Et pourtant,
j'ai eu l'écoute et l'humilité
d'écouter vos retours d'experts,
vos propositions d'amélioration
et de me remettre en question.
J'ai remis en question ma façon de faire
et j'ai changé.
L'apprentissage, c'est une chose.
Le deuxième mot qui est très fort,
c'est « aimer ».
Aimer, c'est un sentiment que, j'espère,
on connait tous dans cette salle
ou du moins qu'on a tous connu
au moins une fois,
mais il n'y a que l'amour qui peut
déclencher une passion suffisante,
il faut vraiment aimer ce qu'on fait
si on veut faire mieux avec moins.
C'est un amour -
je n'aurais pas pu changer,
je n'aurais pas pu trouver
le courage de changer
si je n'aimais pas ce que je faisais.
Et enfin, je rejoins des présentations
qui ont été faites juste avant,
mais insistons sur le mot « faire »
et aujourd'hui il faut oser essayer.
Ici, on est avec des brochettes,
c'est facile,
mais osez essayer, arrêtez de discuter,
de demander des avis, ou autres.
Essayez ! Vous verrez bien.
Souvent ces changements sont faciles,
ils ne demandent pas
des investissements monstres.
Et il n'y a qu'en osant essayer
que vous arriverez à vous améliorer.
J'aimerais finir
sur une question ouverte :
après cette présentation,
vous sentez-vous le courage de faire
un peu mieux dès maintenant?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)